[Music]
straight ahead
on law and crime daily the u.s executes
the ninth federal inmate of the year
what his defense the u.s supreme court
and the victims family all have to say
and i can truly say i forgive them
plus a little boy pull from a well after
six long hours
the heroes who came to his rescue caught
on camera
and will the trial of the four accused
officers in the george ford case be
delayed
we break down the legal motions just
filed
long crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
welcome everyone to law on crime daily
i'm brian buckmart along with terry
austin
the federal government executed a man
for double homicide he committed when he
was 18 years old
lawn crimes daily's anjanet levy has the
latest on the legal maneuvers in this
case
brandon bernard had just hours left to
live when a federal appeals court denied
a stay for execution
reality tv star kim kardashian west
tweeted just after 5 pm
that she had spoken with bernard by
phone and that he said he was
claustrophobic
and was offered a shot of a sedative to
calm him down before they put him in the
chair
and he just didn't want to panic the
last ditch effort to spare brandon
bernard's life ended at the u.s
supreme court attorneys alan dershowitz
and ken
starr joined the legal team in the 11th
hour
asking the high court to issue a 14-day
stay so they could examine the pleadings
in the case
i just found out about the case less
than a week ago and my efforts up until
then was to try to get a
commutation of the sentence and it was
only when that failed
that uh ken and i decided to volunteer
pro bono to
assist the defense and add our name to
the brief
bernard's attorneys had said he took
part in the crime but was not the
shooter
and set fire to the car after
christopher v alva shot
todd and stacey bagley in the head and
that stacy was medically dead when the
fire was set
one of the things i wanted to do was
contact the baggage family let them know
that i felt bad and i wish i could
change things the government painted a
different picture
saying bernard was a gang member who set
the fire in the course of a robbery
and stacy died of smoke inhalation
bernard's attorneys had argued he was on
the lowest tier of the gang
and they claimed they weren't provided
that information before trial
a claim the government denies supreme
court justice sonia sotomayor wrote in a
six-page dissent to the decision to deny
the stay
bernard should not be executed before
his claims have been tested
under the correct standard brandon
bernard died at 9
27 central time on thursday night at the
prison in terre haute indiana
his lawyer robert owen wrote brandon
made one terrible mistake at age 18
but he did not kill anyone and he never
stopped feeling shame
and profound remorse for his actions in
the crime that took the lives of todd
and stacy bagley
and he spent the rest of his life
sincerely trying to show
as he put it that he was not that person
now i spoke exclusively with alan
dershowitz about his involvement in this
case and he said he actually learned
about it just in the last week from his
wife who is a neuropsychologist
and she was particularly concerned that
brandon bernard was sentenced to death
when he was just 18 years old there's
been a lot of discussion about how
young men are less mature at that age
and more impulsive
dershowitz also talked to me a little
bit about how he started
talking with people at the white house
about commuting bernard's sentence to
life without parole
you said you tried to get a commutation
did you reach out to president trump
i reached out to the white house i spoke
to everybody i could speak to in the
white house
um and made my pitch they were very
respectful
they listened to me and uh ultimately
decided uh
not to grant the commutation you know
even if you believe in the death penalty
you're supposed to reserve it for the
worst of the worst and
this man at age 40 is not the worst of
the worst
his crime was terrible but not the worst
of the worst and probably not
a technically capital crime
now i've also reached out to ken starr
but was told he is not available or
would not be available for comment
now as you saw at the top of the
broadcast georgia bagley todd bagley's
mother spoke to the media
after the execution in terre haute
indiana
she actually witnessed what happened
last night
the apology and the remorse that was
shown
to the family and the fact that
they regretted their acts at that time
helped very much to heal my heart
and i can truly say i forgive them
and just an absolutely terrible
situation for the bagley family you can
only imagine what they've been going
through and the pain they've endured
all of these years also a terrible loss
for brandon bernard's family he had two
daughters
just a terrible situation any way you
look at it brian there are seriously no
winners in this case
yeah absolutely no winners here um and
jeanette
it was truly down to the wire how close
were they getting to getting a state
bernard
yeah i think that was particularly
disappointing for
bernard's uh supporters and his legal
team they were very close they only
needed
one more justice to join justices kagan
breyer and sotomayor to be granted cert
and to get the stay they were asking for
just a 14-day stay
so professor dersowitz and ken starr
could review the pleadings in the case
and then
possibly argue in front of the supreme
court
professor dershowitz said he thought
they had a really good chance if they
could have gotten some type of oral
argument to argue before the
court that they would have had a
successful result
and terry i guess the question is what
now i know the arguments may be moot
because he's
already been executed but do they still
push to kind of clear his name in some
way shape or form
well you know i think that there's not
much obviously they can do as far as his
life is concerned
but as far as future lives are concerned
i think getting involved earlier
wherever possible
and i think we had it right here as far
as
this is not the type of case that
deserves the death penalty it's a
horrible case
but life in prison probably would have
been the right answer for this
particular man
and angenette i know this is not the
only person who is scheduled for
execution right
yeah that's right brian just a day after
brandon bernard alfred bourgeois he
is scheduled to be executed by lethal
injection at the very same prison in
terre haute indiana
he was convicted back in 2002 of
torturing and molesting
and killing his young daughter and his
attorneys have raised concerns about his
intellectual
abilities they say he um is
intellectually disabled
the department of justice of course
disagrees with that opinion
all right another death penalty appeal
was affirmed this one by the ohio
supreme court of a convicted killer
sean great was found guilty of murdering
and kidnapping two women in 2018.
great argued in his appeal that his
lawyers were deficient because they did
not request a change of venue
the ohio court ruled there was no
reversible error in his proceedings
saying his death sentence was both
appropriate and proportionate to his
crimes
he also pled guilty to murdering three
other people one of the victims
bodies was found naked and bound in a
closet a third victim escaped from his
home
while he was sleeping by calling 9-1-1
9-1-1 what is the address to your
emergency
fourth street laundromat
where is he sleeping at
in the bedroom please hurry
does he have a weapon he's got a taser
are you tied up now yeah but i kind of
freed myself
are they in the way we have officers
were sending
still ahead on law and crime daily why
one of the ex-cops in the george floyd
case is crying foul
but first an incredible rescue caught on
camera the heroes who pulled a
four-year-old boy
out of a well next
[Music]
welcome back a four-year-old boy is safe
after falling down into a well
first responders are being hailed as
heroes in texas for working to rescue
him
they're estimating he fell in
approximately 4 30. so we freed them
shortly after 10 30. so we're already
looking at six hours of him being
in in that hole we were able to chip
away
at the wall of the hole that was exposed
from the hole that we dug parallel to it
we're able to break that away in
sections and then finally get to them
and and free him from that hole
we just have to think of everything that
he's dealing with down there
also making sure that we control our our
emotions
our adrenaline and we have to work
through that to make sure that we make
sound safe decisions
we got to make sure our rescuers are
safe it felt great to see
him come out of that hole when we
carried him out and he was
crying but he was talking uh everybody
cheered and clapped i mean
everybody around that hole all the first
responders were we're just happy that we
were able to
successfully remove them from them
[Applause]
absolute heroes one and all there that
helped that rescue that small boy
an update in the george floyd case one
of the former officers is asking to
delay the trial
accusing the state of several violations
attorneys for two towns say prosecutors
failed to timely turn over
15 000 pages of discovery allegedly
violating the court's order
eight times one of the biggest
accusations is a report the fbi issued
of an unrecorded interview with the
medical examiner the me noted that floyd
died from a combination of health
problems
as well as police restraint before he
was on the ground
floyd's family hired forensic
pathologist dr michael baden to conduct
an independent autopsy
dr bodden reached a different conclusion
the autopsy shows
that mr floyd had no underlying
medical problem that caused or
contributed
to his death the
cause of death in my opinion is asphyxia
due to compression of the neck
when he said i can't breathe
unfortunately
many police are under the impression if
you can talk
that means you're breathing that is not
true i am
talking and talking and talking and not
breathing in front of you
so the the concept that a person says i
can't breathe like
mr garner like in this instance
uh means you should take it seriously
all right terry as a defense attorney i
tend to agree with tao's lawyer here
you're saying you knew of this interview
that could have helped my client and
slept on it for months
how do you see this motion playing out
in court you know i think this was a
serious mistake by the prosecution the
interview of the medical examiner
took place in july and the state knew
about it they're saying at least
you know in august and they withheld the
information until october 28th that's a
long time so
i think that the motion might prevail
and i think that they might get
more time to actually look at this
evidence it's exculpatory evidence and
they should have been able to see it
sooner and the state
should have revealed it before they did
yeah and that's a brady violation
they're supposed to reveal that
information immediately
kind of looking elsewhere though it
looks like this case is really gearing
up to be a battle of the experts you've
got
baker in one side and bottom and the
other how do you think this rumble's
going to work out when the trial starts
expert against expert you know it's
interesting usually the
medical experts are very important in a
case like this you know the
cause and manner of death are very
critical
here was he expiciated because of the
pressure that was on his back in his
neck
or you know was it drugs and a heart
attack i think here it's not going to be
as important and the reason i say that
is this i think the jury has the video
and i think that they can determine
based on the video what their answer is
yeah that video is going gonna play a
huge part here in this trial when it
starts up whenever it does
but let's continue on coming up on law
and crime daily the latest in the
criminal prosecution of the accused
parkland shooter
plus court cam season three is out and
we have the biggest and perhaps most
unusual courtroom moments
caught on camera after the break
it's a small world but you might not
expect running into someone you've
crossed path with
in court law and crime founder and host
of the a e series court cam
has this funny courtroom moment
next we head over to the miami-dade bond
court of judge mindy s glaser
today judge glaser is presiding over a
hearing for 21 year old elon glenn
sir good morning you have a warrant from
georgia
it is it says for fraud a charge of
fraud
glenn who was in south florida for a
cruise was picked up on an arrest
warrant from his home state of georgia
he now faces extradition there's no way
i can get a bond ma'am
unless you the only thing you can do is
have a lawyer contact the judge in
georgia to see if there's a way to
schedule one it's a fraud charge okay so
so can and will i be able to do that you
can call a lawyer
call whoever you want from the jail
having passed on the information glenn
needs to potentially get out on bond
judge glazer notices an interesting
detail about his case
he was picked up at the cruise what were
you on the breeze
yes yeah me too isn't that cool was the
other nice cruise
i'm glad to be back to work i had to
watch four kids
he was on the cruise this weekend that
just passed yeah yeah
you didn't see me dancing i was the one
you were dancing i was sitting upstairs
in the shade
it was a fun time huh yes
but
judge glazer seemingly appears to side
with his request for bond
citing him as a non-flight risk i mean
if he wanted to flee he could have fled
in what was it
saint martin sink
with their cruise ship flashback all but
over he has two options
you can wave extradition agree to be
sent back to the state of georgia within
15 days
if they don't come pick you up you'll be
released
you can also contest that position and
fight going back
if you can test extradition you can be
held in our jails for up to 90
days are they going to wave
if i don't wait i have to wait for the
15 days no you have to wait in 90 days
oh yeah daddy i'm waiting i'm waiting
glenn waves extradition and is later
picked up by authorities
and extradited back to georgia to face
his fraud charge
definitely an interesting court hearing
but when we come back the pandemic
causes delays in courtrooms around the
country
how the criminal prosecution against
suspected school shooter is going
and why the defense is requesting more
time ahead
[Music]
delays delays delays tara we're seeing
them all over the country
yup brian that's right i've just learned
that harvey weinstein's extradition
from new york to california has been
delayed because of the pandemic
the convicted former movie producer
appeared virtually from prison
in upstate new york his defense and
prosecutors in los angeles
agreed to delay starting the extradition
process until
april 2021 because of rising covet 19
cases
he's facing 11 felony charges of sexual
assault in l.a county
weinstein waived his right to a speedy
trial brian
and in florida concerns over the covet
19 have delayed a mental health
evaluation
for the accused parkland shooter
nicholas cruz
is charged with murdering 17 people at
marjory stoneman douglas high school in
2018.
his team of public defenders want him
evaluated for mental competency
as they work on his defense prosecutors
are seeking the death penalty
it's still unclear what defense he will
put on at trial
his defense attorneys say they need an
evaluation done in person
because a virtual one just won't cut it
we have discussed the pros and cons of
that with some of our experts
and it's not ideal they need to be in
person
with any um
client that they're assessing because
it's not just
the their face that they will be
observing but there's a lot of other
components i'm not
a forensic psychologist but i have
discussed that with them and it's just
not ideal
i can also tell you that our experts are
not willing to travel
as well so i mean it's it's twofold it's
will they get on a plane
and then and will they go into the jail
um they have modified their lives
uh to being
mindful of the cbc guidelines they've
cancelled
vacations they've canceled holidays
holiday arrangements
so it's not their hesitation to travel
and to assess mr cruz is is not specific
to him
it's in consideration of the pandemic in
general
an attorney for the jails says they've
done everything possible to try to
accommodate
the defense's request
everything that they have uh requested
that they requested at the last hearing
like
rapid testing um we found a way to get
done
there was going to be about 15 over 1500
square feet of
space for the expert evaluations to uh
to be conducted in um along what we sent
them
the the ventilation system
that we have at the jail we sent them
the cleaning products that they
requested
um there's not much more that the
sheriff's office can
do to accommodate this but just so you
know the records clear
later down the road we'll just
supplement the record with the with the
emails
the hearing ended unresolved and the
judge set another status hearing for
january
now terry unfortunately like so many
cases in the country
i don't see an end in sight but waiting
for a vaccine was one of the arguments
that i heard
could that be asking for too much to
delay this case
it absolutely is asking for too much i
mean if we all waited for the vaccine
we'd really be
on hold and you know it's going to take
a while for everybody to get this
vaccine
and frankly you know it does sound as
though the
prison did all that they could to make
this
examination as safe as possible and even
if they
could not do the exam in person they
could
always do it over zoom i mean you look
at what's going on in the medical
community today
and that's exactly what they're doing
and this is really to evaluate him
psychologically
so i do think that they should have been
able to do it
one in person or two over zoom
yeah but with zoom i understand what
you're saying with everyday people going
to see their doctors and zoom but do you
think there might be a higher level of
hey
you can ask for zoom to get your cough
medicine but for a death penalty case
maybe it has to be in person is that
maybe what the defense is arguing
yes they are arguing that but you know
you saw and you heard on that clip that
the prison system is doing everything
they could to
accommodate what the defense is asking
for to make sure that there's enough
space and everything's clean so i think
they could have done it in person
all right thank you terry and thank you
for joining us here on law and crime
daily we'll see you next time as we
discuss justice
in america
[Music]
you